you good to go excuse me I'm having an
espresso come on man this is the part
where I introduced the show I'll allow
it though make it quick okay
while you're sipping
[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to roll on we
are returning after a few are you done
you're done okay after a few
journalistic
docudrama Adventures sort of audio long
reads if you will yes sprung from the
mind of Adam skolnick into the worlds of
A.I and sustainable travel but today
today we're going to snap back we're
gonna snap back and do an old school OG
rendition of the show where sir Adam
lord of the swim mask and I catch up on
life we're gonna shoot a little bit of
[__] uh share sundry matters of Interest
peaked we're going to answer your
questions uh with a heavy emphasis today
on the questions and answer
peace and then uh we're gonna call it a
day
we got things to do right we're going to
get in and we're gonna get out yeah I
wanna I've got my car uh is getting
detailed out there so I need to be out
of here yes would that be your Tesla
Adam
s why why isn't there a detail thing in
my Pat in my uh compensation package I
think I need Auto in your in your Rider
yeah with the show yeah when I come I
need to get other stuff done well let me
take a look at the download numbers and
we'll see see it depends on how it goes
today don't do that right okay
um but how are you doing man it's been a
minute we've done those other roll-on
shows but we haven't sat down and just
kind of like
you know did a mind melt and I know I
miss you life I miss you miss you too
this is where we connect on different
subjects
over the phone it's nice but like this
is I feel like this is our relationship
yeah right here it's a bond it's a
bromance uh I'm glad you said it
um but uh but happy to be back in this
Chit Chat friendly format that has been
uh you know that people have have
requested it that's true yeah I'm gonna
get into that in a little bit Yeah but
first uh you dropped a banger on the New
York Times once again yeah thank you all
kinds of photographs and I know I didn't
do any of the photos all I was was the
the photo facilitator which is my want
when I collaborate with a photographer
this was Caitlin O'Hara she's fantastic
she's based out of Phoenix
and this was the scar swim which a lot
of swimmers who listen to this will know
exactly what it is for people who don't
know it's a 40 mile open water swim
across the Arizona desert which does not
compute right it's right this crazy
thing there are there's a river called
the Salt River just outside of Phoenix
in Mesa Arizona
and the Salt River is uh was kind of
used for thousands of years to feed kind
of indigenous uh cotton plots and squash
fields and all that so it's always been
kind of this agricultural uh phenomenon
this water that just kind of moves
through the desert and past these
amazing mesas and Buttes and and kind of
eroding Hills with saguaro cactus and
Mesquite it's quite beautiful but they
were damned in the early 20th century to
light up Phoenix and Mesa and to
um and then to feed the Citrus and
cotton fields that came up at that
period of time in the early 20th century
so these these dams are like you know
the Golden Age of American you know
right art deck beautifully constructed
yeah monuments
Ingenuity yeah I know that dams have now
since been thought of to be damaging and
we didn't know what we were doing you
know that's always the case right you
know more later but I mean you gotta say
like these things are spectacular one in
particular the one on Apache Lake
separates Apache from Roosevelt so the
idea is you swim from one end of the dam
to the next and the next day you start
at that the other end of that Dam and
then you swim down to the next Lake and
it's ongoing yeah 40 mile stage race
yeah tent Nine Mile nine nine and a half
mile Nine Mile 17 Mile and then a 10K
swim wow and the 10K swims at night just
to make sure it's not too easy right
yeah I like that this is the natural
progression and evolution of ultra
endurance right we've seen exactly these
ultra distance cycling adventures and
running of course yeah
um and Triathlon but not a lot I mean
there's Marathon swims out there yeah
there's sort of Standalone things but a
stage race ultra marathon swim
competition is pretty cool yeah it's
cool it started about there's been this
is the 10th edition of it
um but there was one year where they
didn't do it uh because of kovid so it
started in 2012 Kent Nicholas who is
basically a uh
um what's this what's the what do I
what's the term I use like they edited
it out uh the lawyer from Breaking Bad
Saul Goodman he's got a Saul Goodman
clients Client List and he's incredibly
charismatic awesome dude
um but has that little Saul Goodman kind
of Twinkle in his eye uh started it
because he's a swimmer and he was
preparing to swim Catalina and so he
would swim a saguaro and he had this
idea because he could swim a three mile
stretch you know and then back so it's a
six mile total swim in Saguaro in an
area that is kind of cordoned off so
boats can't come in because these are
these Lakes you know boaters are always
in there and the party boats like
pontoon boats you know
um but uh so he decided hey what if we
swam all of them so he called some
friends and I don't know it was like
seven or eight people showed up that for
that one I think seven two finish
including Kent and the next year he
stopped swimming it because he was
running it and this year there were 58
swimmers 38 were women and that's the
other thing I didn't know I mean I knew
that there were there's a there's
thousands of these of swim races whether
it's 5K 10K or even longer ones around
the world and then of course there's all
the channel swims which are like kind of
the the gold standard in sport uh but
you're right stage races are are less
common and uh what I didn't know even
though I've covered Open Water Swimming
I didn't realize how dominant women are
in the sport which is really cool I
thought that was and that was so evident
when it's almost two to one women you
can't really even I can't yeah miss that
as the distances get longer the gender
gap uh shrinks uh but there's something
specific about Open Water Marathon
swimming where that Gap is even smaller
than it is in other Endurance Sports
um you know women really distinguish
them themselves in all of endurance
you're saying no I'm saying with
Marathon yeah I think so yeah so that
was great I mean it was it was an
Exquisite race with and what's cool
about this race is you get these people
heads of Channel Association from all
over the United States and all and
people who've swam all these amazing
channels from all over the world they
all show up there and they Trade Secrets
and they like Advocate hey comes from My
Race come to you know I was invited to
like three different races just being
there
um it's one of those kinds of uh flash
points for this community yeah I feel
like it's still like it it resembles
what ultra running probably looked like
in the you know I don't know mid 90s
yeah this this really specific nice very
small insular subculture where everybody
knows everybody uh and it's just pitcher
tent and do the race and nobody notices
kind of thing
um but when you start writing about it
in the New York Times and everybody's
looking for you know what's the next
cool adventure and people are talking
about it on podcasts like this these are
the things that you know the seeds are
planted for this to grow by the way so
uh a couple last thoughts on this though
I wanted to say there was a there were I
met an incredible woman named Sarah
Thomas who I mentioned in the piece you
know Sarah Thomas is she's the first to
swim the English Channel four times in a
row
four times in a row wow you know how you
like drop your stuff on the pool side
and it's cool video and then we all see
it and then do laps right she's doing
that she doesn't think France in England
I mean isn't that amazing that is she
also said how did that take
25 was it 52 hours something like that I
forgot absolutely some crazy number she
swam Lake Powell 100 miles across Lake
Powell or something
um and uh she said my stroke looked
solid that's what she said well there
you go yeah I thought that was nice you
want is that is that what you want on
the gravestone is that the Epitaph Sarah
Thomas his stroke looked solid
um you know why but that she's a
recruiter like that's her day job she's
a recruiter and she said you're coming
in hot from The New York Times she's
gonna tell you that you look good
you're wait you're just counting
in your swim mask and the whole thing I
had the full swim mask
um and she said my stroke of Solomon
then I later found out that people come
to her in Denver say hey I'm thinking
about doing a 5k or 10K and by the time
she's done talking to him they're
training for the English Channel so she
might have right a certain way about her
yeah yeah yeah but there was a uh two
brothers I wanted to tell you about Joe
and John zamantes and they swam doubles
of everything except for the 17 Mile
swim they had their own little zodiac
they swam doubles
and Joe trains all the time John doesn't
even train he hadn't swam since February
and he just
wow so he did 80 miles yeah they did 80
miles they did well they did doubles of
everything except for the 17-Mile swim
oh it just wasn't part of their program
doubles except for the hard day
okay
no that's great amazing yeah pretty
amazing to see these guys just swimming
out there you know like the guy did a
flip turn at the dam I saw him
so pretty cool and it's also cool to see
you know I I fall I have I myself have
fallen into the trap to think of
athletes in a certain body type you know
I've always thought you know we know
what we we think we know what fit is and
Open Water Swimming kind of really
challenges that because people come in
all shapes and sizes and
um you wouldn't pass half these people
on the street and think that's a monster
athlete but these are people that have
done incredible Feats and so you know
it's just I think just it was a reminder
for me to check myself on what I think
an athlete looks like and who an athlete
is because they're everywhere and we
walk past them we have no idea it's like
lockba and Whole Foods you know yeah and
there's something about when the
distances become longer and longer and
longer where the the you know the body
shapes that show up and distinguish them
distinguish themselves in those events
don't fit what you have in your mind
like if you think of the 3100 uh
self-transcendent run in Queens every
year where they just run around the
block like all summer long yeah until
they get 3 100 miles like the people
that are crushing it you would never
pick out of a lineup and say that person
is an athlete and in Open Water Swimming
particularly when cold water is involved
yeah you have to put on a lot of weight
like you need to keep your body warm if
you don't put on that layer of blubber
then you're going to be using so much
energy to keep yourself warm that you're
not going to be able to keep swimming
yeah so you see people who look quite
large who show up and you think that
person isn't fit at all they are very
fit it's just underneath like this added
pad or layer that allows them to you
know stay in the water for extreme
periods of time and also float better
yeah so it's a weird thing it's uh
they cover themselves in Crisco and like
all that well yeah yeah that's that's
the tin now it's like diaper rash cream
now is the main one
um have you ever thought about doing
Crush that channel you'd be [__]
great
don't like cold water but you could do
tsugaro like in Japan or you could do
yeah I thought I thought about it I mean
I I did you know when my back was
causing me problems at the outset and
running long distances was sort of off
the table for a period of time I thought
well let me I signed up for the
um the Key West yeah swim which I think
was 10K and then like the flip turns
really aggravated my back and I had to
back off so right now I'm just about
getting well right before I can consider
yeah you were thinking but like putting
yeah like something like like a race
like that you know that you were just at
does sound interesting to me I think
that sounds fun because I've never done
a pure swim Ultra and you know I think
that I would be
fairly okay at that it was super fun you
know like it was it was cold like
average temperature I think in the
morning was like 55 but it got up to
like the low 60s and the air temperature
is so warm like they can't insisted I
get any wanted me to get in for at least
a half an hour and I was in there for
like hour 45 and I didn't you know I
could have kept going it's just that I
got dropped by basically everybody in
the field but um but it was just keep
diving down looking for fish no it was
it was like you know Green a lot of
nutrients in the water the river was
like a Green River
um I mean the People Are Awesome
um I definitely recommend it uh you know
if you do feel motivated I mean it's
it's cool I mean swimming is your your
thing it's fun to see these uh athletes
Catherine breed and Michael rice were
really amazing to watch the two the two
winners
um so that was that how are you man what
you've been You've Been Everywhere
um I'm good but why don't we stick a pin
in it for right now take a quick break
and we'll be right back if you have yet
to try srimu the insanely delicious
artisanal plant-based cheeses that are
literally redefining that sector Turning
Heads impressing even the snootiest
palettes and also disappearing off
shelves at airwan markets as their most
popular cheese product well now is your
moment because the dairy-free vegan
paleo keto low carb and gluten-free
Delights that our srimu are right now
exclusively available to RRP listeners
and only RRP listeners with a special
deal sign up today for any subscription
and receive a complimentary
Eternal box valued at 48 this box has
three amazing flavors including
everything inspired by the classic
everything bagel fire inspired by spicy
Pepper Jack and imagine beautifully
infused with coconut lemon and blue
butterfly pea flour this amazing deal is
only available for new subscriptions to
get your complimentary box visit
shreemu.com RRP that's
srimu.com RRP and sign up for a
subscription today that's shreemu.com
RRP available now through June 30. you
know how they say a lawyer is his own
worst Advocate or a doctor his own worst
patient sure yeah well I think that
adage could be extended to podcasters uh
being the last to take their own counsel
because
I was so heavily influenced by all of
your inspirational reporting on
sustainable travel that in the last
month I have flown to and from
Italy London and Northern California and
in three days I'm heading to Australia
well so I will purchase carbon offsets
for all of these things but I would
hardly call that sustainable travel
let's not do the unsustainable travel
it's sustainable for my soul yes uh but
uh perhaps not in the best interest of
the planet instead of carbon offsets
let's make a donation of the carbon I've
set price to treat people in Los Angeles
I can do that yeah it's easy yeah um but
yeah I got back from Europe we were in
Italy uh Julie and I co-hosted
um our Retreat that we've done many
times in the Tuscan Countryside I would
say that it's mostly Julie's Retreat she
takes over and you know spins her magic
but we had an incredible time in this
beautiful location the whole family
Lawrence and Sienna yeah this place
called Borgo is Alana all our kids came
we had an amazing group that bonded
immediately and it was you know
everything we hoped it would be
Community Connection food meditation
yoga breath work journaling Tea Ceremony
fire ceremony wow a little witchcraft
music some hiking what kind of
Witchcraft well you know Julie doing
fire ceremony Anything Can Happen she's
like we did she's like the cool fire uh
sorcery she's a fire Priestess
yeah
um man yeah uh it was it was really cool
uh and uh although I would have
preferred my back to be in a little
better condition so I could have gone
running on the trails and right
that kind of thing um that was a bit of
a bummer in fact one day I was kind of
totally laid up
um which wasn't great but it was a
really
um great reminder of why it's important
to you know spend time with groups of
people in uh you know in and away from
your daily life it was just fantastic
and very nourishing so let me ask you as
we're running these Retreats is there a
level of customer service involved
yes we got a whole team you got a whole
team Mel is our producer she's amazing
and unbelievable with yeah all of that
yeah yeah she's fantastic
um
I recorded a live podcast with uh one of
the attendees Dr Alan Desmond who's a
outstanding plant-based uh
gastroenterologist in the UK we were
very lucky to have him so I'll be
sharing that at some point he's a return
guest you've had him no I haven't had
him before no I haven't I haven't so
I've heard him he's fantastic yeah he's
making all these videos on Instagram
that pop up on eating your fiber and
stuff like that yeah yeah he was cool uh
and and that Retreat I had announced you
know when we did roll on last when I was
announcing it that it was going to be
our last one uh and it was so rewarding
that who knows like there's a question
mark there as to whether we're going to
do it again or not count us in yeah well
we're not committed yet come spend two
days with me
yeah
with Adam instead an apostle in Florence
we would love to have you all that all
the skolnik heads coming out of the
woodwork yeah to hang out in Italy yes
um obviously I'll keep everyone posted
on that uh and and the website for that
is our plantpowerworld.com but this is
kind of like a static landing page but
again you know I'll share when we have
clearly your your uh posts from there
were awesome I mean I I felt the energy
you know we had Leia uh you know our our
photographer that was originally our
babysitter and Nanny that Julie realized
had quite an extraordinary eye and
invested in developing her and then
allowed her to like hired her to
photograph
um two of her cookbooks when she could
have hired any food photographer to do
it uh and Leia was just a you know a
young person at the beginning of her
career and she really thrives in the
opportunity and is amazingly talented
and has gone on to become quite a
notable photographer and videographer
and Storyteller who works with Zach Bush
and his Farmer's footprint organization
but she came and you know did all the
all those amazing photographs that I've
been sharing and there's tons more like
I don't want to like bleed the feed but
like there were so many incredible
pictures that she took from Julie is a
powerful woman yeah she is yeah she's
she's good she's very good at spotting
potential and talent that's cool but
then also not just spotting it but then
wanting to develop it like getting
fulfilled from helping people reach
their potential she's really good at
that yeah
um and then I went to London for a week
uh with Jaya our youngest stayed on
Portobello Road in the heart of Notting
Hill which was amazing and just kind of
did the tourist thing went to the Tate
modern I love the tape modern we saw A
Streetcar Named Desire in the West End
oh really yeah which was cool starring
Paul Mezcal oh wait a remake well yeah
it's just up it's it's been playing with
great reviews in the west end and it's
starring this guy uh Paul muscal okay as
Stanley Kowalski who is on the cusp of
becoming a big deal Indie fan indie film
fans will know him from a movie called
after sun that came out last year okay
uh in which he was great but
apparently I heard that he's the lead in
The Gladiator 2 the new Gladiator movie
that really Scott is doing so maybe he
really went and saw A Streetcar Named
Desire in the West End maybe I don't
know well after some there was one other
movie that he did
um what's it called I forget right now
uh so he's definitely like with young
people like they all they're all about
this guy okay
um so that was really fun I went to this
amazing David hockney exhibit like an
immersion exhibit I shared some stuff on
Instagram stories about that where you
go into this cavernous sort of gigantic
Warehouse type room and they project in
360 Degrees hockney's art in this kind
of Pastiche
um uh
uh you know kind of overlapping semi
semi animated Style with not voice over
by him but kind of guided like sort of
recorded stuff his voice recorded over
the years like reflecting on his career
and his art and that was super cool
especially all the stuff about Los
Angeles and why he loves la I love
hockey how he painted Los Angeles you
know he's no one had really captured it
and the desert also the desert love for
the desert yeah which was uh which was
just I mean High recommend it was one of
the coolest things I've ever seen it's
like the same is it the same people that
did the van Gogh and now they're doing
hockey I don't know I know there's that
van Gogh immersion um I don't know if
it's the same people and I haven't gone
to that exhibit yet so I'm not sure uh
uh but this was at a place called
Lightroom
um if you're in London you should
definitely put that on your list it was
very cool I went to uh you know the
Tashan Flagship that used to be yeah
there used to be or it wasn't a flag
actually it was the one on Beverly
Boulevard yeah not the flagship store in
Beverly Hills which is fabulous but this
they had like on Suites or in Beverly I
think they had this gallery that they
took over and they were doing like
pop-ups they did a Bowie thing they did
Michael uh uh the shark photographer why
am I the Mueller Mueller oh yeah he did
a thing there yeah and they did they did
hockney I mean hockney was amazing there
yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's but that's
static you know this yeah I would love
to see this yeah it's very cool yeah
um and uh made more kind of cool and
interesting
um because we were staying at my friend
Sasha's Office flat
um and he hap he splits time between LA
and uh and London uh podcast fans will
remember him from the Anvil episode and
that the episode that I did with him and
Jamie Dornan over the movie that he made
for HBO my dinner with irvae okay uh so
Sasha writer filmmaker right and also uh
used to live
up in this neighborhood in the Hills
where hockney's uh
um Studio was right across the street
and he developed like a friendship with
him and would go have tea with him so he
had all these insights about like that's
cool you know hockney yeah hockey is
still alive right I know yeah he's I
mean he's quite old now yeah he's still
yeah he's still around and you know what
I took from that
was the purity of how this guy lived his
life like he in on some level is very
simple like he's like I like to make
pictures I like to sketch I like to draw
I can just sit in nature and do it and
I've been doing it for 50 years and I
still love doing it like he's a guy who
is authentically who he is who's
pursuing this thing that he loves for
for the sake of the doing right yeah and
this amazing career and and kind of
um uh you know library of work that he's
created that the world has fallen in
love with is is really a byproduct of
just continuing to do that thing and in
the most simplistic way is just like I
like this you know yeah but there's a
profundity in that oh yeah as well
there's a zen zen yeah like a depth to
it right you know it's interesting like
I I think I mean I'm no art historian so
correct me if I'm wrong many people who
know more than me uh but I'm pretty sure
nobody had put swimming pools on canvas
in a fine art way before hockey I think
hockney was like the first to really
Pioneer that I've heard that as well
that might be apocryphal I'm not sure
but you know he talks a lot about the
swimming pool stuff and how he tried to
capture water and how it's always moving
and every swimming pool that he painted
was different and you know all of that's
yeah cool
um yeah did that I happened to be there
during the coronation Insanity which was
super fun were you there well I mean
it's all going down you know at uh at
Westminster right so like no I watched
that on TV with Sasha who also happens
to be a writer on the crown so oh really
yeah like he's like he's got the Royals
dialed uh so that was fun
um the processional between the
um Westminster Abbey and Buckingham
Palace that we didn't go down and stand
in the room to witness that but I did
watch on television because I exited the
Abbey and got into the gold-plated uh
horse and buggy Carriage Contraption you
know I mean the whole thing is like so
insane never been inspired by Prince
King Charles it's so strange yeah you
know I've never been into them this
institution still exists and captures
the fascination of the world at a time
when we've we're seeing just this you
know increasing gash between between the
Haves and the have-nots and the economic
disparity and yet there is this
institution that for some reason
continues to inspire a lot of people and
uh serves as this symbol for an Empire
that doesn't quite exist anymore but for
some reason uh retains a level of
resonance which is curious
yeah I mean you know I mean I think that
probably the Haves and Have Nots they've
always been the Kings
I mean monarchs not great yeah no say
what you want though about King Charles
at least he's an environmentalist that
is true I mean he he sort of came he he
came around the corner yeah like that
right yeah yeah it's an organic food
entrepreneur I think and people investor
yeah yeah exactly yeah um I had Tim
Spector in here who's very prominent uh
UK doctor
um and the guy behind Zoe which is this
you know sort of
um microbiome app service
and he had very nice things to say about
the king and his interest in improving
health and yeah so there is that that's
genuine yeah I don't know so uh I will
say that uh at one point walking around
London I I looked up and I happened to
be on gouge Street oh yeah Tube Station
was right around the corner huge tubes
at which point I snapped a picture and
uh texted you and immediately uh
facetimed our friend William Gooch who
is in the midst of his transcon run uh
from California to New York City amazing
uh in the Heartland in the middle of the
country uh so we should do a gooch
update well you know what where is he
right now let's look I think he's in
Ohio is he Ohio recording this on Monday
I believe so I didn't I didn't watch the
latest Vlogs he's in the final like
Thousand Miles I think he's crushing it
he seems to be getting stronger and
stronger and his his uh I think his
mileage last week was you know bigger
than ever he was hitting like 62 mile
days uh I mean he's a beast he looks
like an athlete he does yeah he looks
like an athlete what's that what's so
did we talk about him before like he was
a former I don't know if he was
professional I think we I think we've
talked a lot about him no but it first
came up as the hypebeast slash Ultra
Runner no I know fashion model yeah he
but he's like a former rugby player he
was like a 220 pound rugby player I
didn't know that yeah and then his
mother died from cancer and he went on
this run to support cancer and kind of
process that loss yeah I didn't know
about the rugby part yeah so this whole
all of his running is to raise money uh
you know in memory of his mother right
and so he's been doing it since then and
but he's like I said he was uh he's he
was like a big beast of a of uh kind of
like David in a way like a beast of a
Navy SEAL guy that became an ultra and
the body's different but still strong
he's not like a weedy little kind of
like endurance guy like he's yoked yeah
not at all yeah and and that apparently
is controversial is it really the some
of the stories and the other Vlog so
there's some haters out there I saw that
because you know let's let's face it
William likes his Gucci he's not afraid
to uh have a you know sit for high tea
or or wear a bathrobe or talk about a
skincare regimen no and that is not the
mold from which the ultra Runner uh you
know emerges so listen it's a very
different type of person and I think
there's people out there who don't like
that and started to think this guy isn't
for real and all of that hate got
directed towards him which he then
Channel and fueled into just upping his
mileage every single day some dude
showed up to try to prove that he was
cheating oh I didn't know that yeah
that's a there's a it's one of the
episodes of the audacious report docs I
don't know if you've been seeing all the
mini docs they're fantastic I know which
are which are
um filmed edited directed by Rhys
Robinson our friend who first came on
one of our Retreats and ended up uh
doing a bunch of content uh for us and
working on the podcast back in the day
he's just he's fantastically talented
yeah and and Robbie uh is like the crew
chief he's he does he looks great on his
mustache is world class he's awesome too
and he's been he sent me a text the
other day from like the world's largest
gift shop or something like things you
find on Route 66 yeah yeah yeah and uh
but they've been you know it's been
great to see love the audition support
and I'm thinking about getting newcom
they're really they're really selling me
on this Newcomb yeah it's working it's
seems to be working well I like how
William post's newcom update like he how
much he slept and then his it's it's all
about like that restorative regenerative
nap time where that technology and
protocol will drop you into this
restorative State and in a very brief
period of time you know kind of allow
you to bounce back and Robbie swears by
it
um and obviously you know it's working
for William and they're a sponsor of
that um of that feat so that's cool I'm
excited to see it all happen are you are
you thinking about you were at the
starting line you think about going to
New York for the Finish
depends when when is the what's the
anticipated date they were going to do
it in less than 62 days from the start
date but at this point I think they're
got to be under 60 like they're shaving
days off yeah so I'd like to I mean
obviously like I'm not running right now
but I'm gonna look into that it would be
cool to be there yeah yeah it would be
really cool yeah Casey neistat was at
hella's that's right right this week
is coming up on is it his six-year
anniversary of the runs posted like he's
doing a group run in in New York City to
celebrate he is okay yeah I don't know
what day it is exactly but you know
that's 600 like 6 000 days or something
like that there was a six involved and
it was big dude
um while I was in London I also did a
couple media appearances I would I
guessed it on this uh podcast called
Diary of a CEO which is a pretty big
show in the UK and and growing really
quickly all over the world I think it's
like third or second of fun make a show
in the UK uh hosted by this guy Stephen
Bartlett who's a bit of a UK celebrity
entrepreneur turned podcaster who
um became well known as the youngest
guest judge on Dragon's Den which is
their version of Shark Tank okay
um and it was it was a real honor to do
his show like I I think what he's doing
is is interesting he's super pro great
interviewer so cool that's coming out
soon
um is it kind of like a how I built this
type of No it's it's more it's more
directed than that it's really not I
mean I think it started as a business
type podcast how did you become
successful but now it's gotten so big
that he has all different kinds of
people
um but he's very good at asking
questions and kind of getting beneath
the beneath
and uh he invited Jai and I to join him
for the Manchester United West Ham game
which was super fun I had never been to
a premier league uh football match
before so I went in knowing absolutely
nothing like a complete Dullard you know
for the experience Stephen was very
patient with my ignorance uh you know
around this game that everybody else in
the world uh is a fan of and feels about
we're like why don't they pick up the
ball Stephen yeah I did have some
questions what is the pitch
no no one's pitching it yeah uh but that
was that was really an incredible treat
and you know shocking at how little uh
uh you know I know about that sport but
sort of like F1 or like anything really
the more you learn about something the
more kind of invested you become in
following it and I I you know started to
fall in love and it's the it's like the
beautiful game but it's also like
worldly it it spreads so far and wide
because it's actually pretty simple you
know you took a ball over there right
you can know nothing and follow it yeah
right and that gets complex from there
right basically yeah um and I also did
uh Chris Evans breakfast show on uh
virgin UK radio uh for those that if you
know you know Chris is a legend
broadcasting Legend anybody you know in
the UK knows who he is he hosts this you
know gigantic morning radio show to a
massive audience every weekday morning
for those that don't know
um he's just a you know a quality guy
like so positive and optimistic and
enthusiastic and
and is also a fan of the podcast like
he's he is always talking about the show
in fact I think he did today he was
talking about Neil pasaricha our latest
guest on the show this morning
um
and because of his his uh enthusiasm for
the RRP we end up like doing better in
the UK than we do in the U.S really
solely because of uh of his you know
kind of
um free promotion which is very kind and
generous of him he's our secret
marketing weapon deploying positive
awareness across the British Empire he's
he's amazing yeah and like um yeah and
big Runner and just you know all the
good stuff right like a lot of his crew
are marathons yeah exactly yeah he's you
know a bunch of people who work for him
producer Etc
um are all running marathons and his
like right-hand guys getting ready to do
Western States like is that right he got
in the lottery yeah and he'd run UTMB
um so I got to meet you know some of his
staff and I had met Chris once prior but
I'd never done a show before so that was
really fun it did not disappoint we had
a really good time doing it but the main
thing and the reason primarily I am
bringing it up is that not only is Chris
uh you know a big uh podcast man of this
podcast he is the number one roll-on fan
he just might be king of the skull
Knicks he loves you so much Adam
basically 75 of our 20 minutes on air
was devoted to the Adoration of Adam
so I'm not sure I'm not sure about yours
I don't know how you feeling today but
if you need a little boost like maybe
check out you know Chris and I on the on
the radio this morning no thank you I I
did I did listen to the interview loved
it I mean he's so high energy and so
positive it's like
you know someone had called in on we
didn't include the question in this show
but it was like you know how come
there's not more good not more good news
people out there spreading the good
energy and all of that and he is one of
those people in media and at a real high
level that does it and
um it's really cool to hear that he's
responded I did hear it he's also not
only the number one roll-on fan he's
he's head of the faction that wants to
go back to strictly the OG form when I
say roll and I mean old school yeah yeah
he didn't have a lot to say about the
docu series
he did want to talk about you know
streaming choices and like all the
knucklehead stuff that we do yeah and
look you know he's
he's uh he knows from whence he comes
right this is a guy who's been around
for a very long time and he told me like
roll-on is great Rapport is really hard
and rare and you guys have it and
there's something really fun and unique
about that don't overthink it like just
keep doing that thing and you know that
was encouraging to hear it was
encouraging it's cool it's really cool
to hear that that that plays and uh and
because he used an example of he had a
music show and he'd have like the best
bands in the world on there like the
biggest acts in the world you too
whoever and
um they would have this Chit Chat
interview that was in that kind of off
the cuff
and then they'd cut to the band playing
a song like a live rendition and people
would turn the channel like it was the
off the cuff impromptu stuff that you
you didn't know it was going to happen
it interests people more than going to
something that seems overly produced or
something more familiar right the the
the the prologue that you think is sort
of fluff and not that important becomes
the thing ironically that the people are
tuning in for rather than the main act
exactly I think we do have some uh
subjects lined up to continue to explore
but maybe we do it in in some a looser
format like we're doing now we'll see
yeah but I will say that uh that Chris
is a big fan of streaming Rex
he told me he's like we all here you
know ended up watching White Lotus
because you guys talked about it I was
like you had to hear about White Lotus
from us it's surprising but you don't
know what really transfers right like
what you know they have so many shows
that are huge shirts that we never see
and it must be both ways right right
right right anyway it was a total joy
and honor to do Chris's show I have so
much respect and admiration for him uh
and we love you Chris thank you so much
I mean he has been so gracious and
generous with his support for this show
it's just you know it's it's
extraordinary so Chris I know you're
listening he's listening right now he's
listening right this second
uh Chris man hey thank you so much for
the support for listening for you know
talking about the show advocating for
the show and for a roll-on it's really
cool to you know I appreciate all of
Richie's listeners it's very cool to
hear that you're listening and for the
advice and for the and for the love you
know the just the idea that there's
positive kind of media happening at a
really high level is super cool yeah
absolutely all of which brings us to our
hotly anticipated uh media diet recipes
which are coming right up on the heels
of our discussion about White Lotus uh
but first let's hear from a couple of
the sponsors that help make this show
possible I feel like most people wanna
eat better they want to improve their
diets absolutely have you heard of it
I've heard of it this trips up so many
people we thought hey we know a couple
things about how to do this a few so we
created this thing called the plant
power meal planner that is this
beautiful offering whereby you gain
access to literally thousands of
plant-based rice recipes that you can
totally customize based upon your
preferences your allergies your
peccadillos it integrates with grocery
delivery so all the ingredients that you
need get shipped right to your door so
you can make the stuff that you've
pre-selected and we all could use a
little inspiration and support when
preparing meals for our families in our
busy lives so we hope you join us no
matter what your eating style is we have
our arms open wide and we've saved you a
space at our family table to join us in
eating more healthy vibrant plant-based
meals visit meals Dot richroll.com
[Laughter]
media diet that people have asked for it
and we deliver what the people want Adam
what's in your queue
Lakers Lakers and more like Lakers I'm
blinded by the purple and gold over here
with the Wardrobe change but speaking of
La wash beef very a very La slash uh
yeah that's a wild K-Town meets
Calabasas chaotic ride yeah uh with a
standout turn by our friend David Cho
amazing came in here recently we haven't
published that episode yet but I did
round two with him we saw him coming who
saw him as like a great actor coming
yeah yeah he really acquitted himself
yeah quite well yes um going Toe to Toe
with Steve Yuan and uh and Ali Wong I
mean Steve youn we know is spectacular I
don't know if you saw the what's the
Oscar uh oscar-nominated one I forget
but yeah he has an Oscar nomination yeah
yeah and then uh that's a great movie
takes place in 80s in Arkansas and like
to compare that character to like what
he played in beef and then Ali Wong I
mean she is incredible what what an
incredible artist yeah it's a superstar
turn for her and it was just fresh in
its chaos yeah and then enter David Cho
and it's like just you know I know a
whole new level of chaos like an
unpredictability
um we talk about it a lot I'll I don't
want to spoil that conversation but it's
pretty special and what's funny about
watching beef is I know all those
locations yeah it's filmed all around
this area here like I know that house
like I know exactly where that house is
where Ali Wong lives and it's and La too
right so it's both right it's kind of
kind of going back well it's certain
yeah it's a it's it obviously has a lot
to say about class yeah yeah as well
um super super fun I I found it to be
the freshest thing I've seen since the
first season of Atlantic Atlanta it
reminds me of the first season of
Atlanta and it's kind of you know
um not exactly the same tone Atlanta's
more of a straight up comedy I think
although this is very funny
um but at least the first season of
Atlanta was but similar kind of like
offbeat
um you know abstract kind of sure yeah
everyone is terrible in this show right
that's the difference Atlanta you have
people to root for this show there's no
wonderful speaking of a show where
everybody is terrible
yes
there's a little show on HBO you might
have heard of it a little baby show
called
success success succession yeah I've
been watching some sessions not exactly
a hot take to say like succession is in
your is in your queue but
um that show is just on a whole other
level yeah yeah yeah that's out there I
I you know I don't wanna I don't know
how much spoiler we want to get into but
this season there was a noticeable
departure and
um I've been kind of like
off this season a little bit more than
on than I have been in the past but the
election night was so I mean that was
it yeah yeah it's just unbelievably well
considered piece of Television amazing
it was an art form in and of itself I
agree created by a bunch of Brits to
tell the most American story with a
level of incisiveness
um
that uh I haven't seen you know I mean
it's so reminiscent of the 2016 election
um and done with satire but also with a
heaviness to it that distinguished that
episode from many of the others like I'm
all in on this season and uh it's just
been riveting for me to watch you're all
in on the on the current drama as to
where it's going it's interesting Roman
is uh making his power move I mean he's
gone full Darth Vader he's going full we
don't want his phone
it's dark it's it's getting really dark
yeah yeah yeah as as Jeremy Strong who
plays Kendall Roy has said it's Richard
III which if you know that play you have
a good sense of where the chips may fall
at the end right but we shall see
yeah two more episodes left all I know
is
Kendall won't win
well even if he wins he doesn't win he
loses that's the thing right nobody's
winning no this you know and it's not a
mystery it's not a Greg might win it's
not a mystery box show either it's not
about like some big reveal I think it's
just gonna be a situation in which
nobody wins and the Earth is scorched
and the rich people sort of ride off
into the sunset without repercussions
for their behavior you know it's going
to have a kind of very Grim dire
uh you know sort of thing to say about
but that's always there right like the
fact is that
that's part of why the characters are
not ultimately likable although you you
feel yourself feeling for them but
they're not likable because it they're
the stakes are
like in terms of their lifestyle nothing
will change their lives will be at a
certain level no matter when Roman says
like it doesn't matter right like he's
like nothing matters power that's why
power is the currency that matters
because everything else is already done
yeah it's already taken care of anyway
yeah I don't want to spoil too much more
but yeah you know I I found it to be
just on a whole other level yeah that
that those are the two shows I've
watched but it sounds like you've
watched a lot of I have stuff
um let's see it's been so long it's been
so long since we've done this I guess
the first thing because it's top of mind
that I would want to make sure that
everybody is seen is All Quiet on the
Western Front there's obviously nothing
new on this recommendation uh just you
know it got a ton of baftas and and
Oscars I might have even previously
mentioned it on the show uh obviously
also based on the classic 1929 novel
about World War One Told from the point
of view not of the Victor but of a young
German soldier at the very end of that
devastating uh conflict and this movie
was a bit of a sleeper I was a late
Comer to it
um but when I watched it I was just
absolutely riveted by its exquisiteness
It's haunting it's horrifying it's
beautiful and it's got this aftertaste
that really lives with you that sticks
with you and the reason I'm bringing it
up now is because yesterday
I had Leslie Patterson on the podcast
who is the film's oscar-nominated
screenwriter oh how cool which in and of
itself is amazing and worthy of uh you
know an appearance on the podcast uh but
her story is just gonna absolutely melt
your brain I can't wait that show comes
out uh in addition to winning the bafta
and being nominated for an Oscar for her
for her script and all kinds of other
accolades uh she's also a five-time
world champion in triathlon
in Xterra and off she run she won three
Xterra World Championships but not in
her past life before getting into screen
filmmaking right during her
screenwriting journey to get the film
made so as this nobody in the business
with no credits she optioned the book in
2006. who would even think that you
could option that book right yeah well
she didn't she thought some studio would
have it tied up and I think it was
Paramount I can't remember which studio
had let an option lapse and it went to
the estate and she was able to negotiate
with the estate and option it and then
she spent 16 years trying to get this
film made
so every 12 to 18 months she would have
to renew the option which was somewhere
between 10 to 15 grand each time and her
way of doing that
was to be a professional triathlete win
races and then use the prize money to
renew the option which she did for many
years she's she went out of pocket over
that period of time over 200 Grand to
keep this thing alive I think they
mortgage their house to keep it going
talk about relief and it's not like oh
she's an athlete and a writer like this
is a person who in 2011 at the Maui
Xterra World Championships she flatted
on the bike fell way behind and then ran
so fast in the Run leg that her split
was exactly the same as Michael Weiss
who won the men's race and 10 minutes
faster than Lance Armstrong like she's
an absolute baller and then in 2016 she
had this protracted uh battle with Lyme
disease it had her like bedridden
forever and [__] you know it took her
years to kind of crawl out of that
finally starts to feel like she's
starting to come back together
and she enters this race
not because she's super fit she's only
just starting to dip her toe back into
being an athlete but because the
option's about to lapse and they have no
money and she doesn't know how she's
going to pay for this thing but she just
can't let
the book go like she's obsessed with
getting this movie made so she goes to
this Xterra Race in Costa Rica and uh
the day before the race
Xterra Off-Road I can't remember which
one
she does what you do which is you Recon
the course like you get on your mountain
bike and you ride around it so you have
a feel for what's happening and she
crashes and she breaks her shoulder
breaks her shoulder no way she can race
her husband convinces her well why don't
you just try to race anyway like you're
pretty good with the one arm drill
and she's like fine you know I guess I
could swim out you know 50 meters and if
it's bad like I'll just stop right we're
here so she does that gets through the
swim comes out I don't know last out of
the water gets on her bike and rides
through the entire field into second
place and then outpaces everyone on the
run and like wins the freaking race and
wins the prize money and just in time
like is able to renew the option holy
[__] and then over the years of
development hell with producers who go
to jail and this person attached and
that person attached
the universe finally conspired to make
this dream happen and she's the director
and writer no just the right she's she's
a screenwriter yeah she's a screen right
it's a great I mean I've given you the
highlights but that's an incredible
podcast that's coming up at some point
so anyway in preparation for that
podcast if you have not seen All Quiet
on the Western Front I strongly suggest
you check it out what a that sounds like
there should be a hearts of Darkness
type uh documentary about that movie you
know what I mean like well yeah it's a
biopic in its own right right yeah you
know so like her life story is insane
she she played rugby when she was seven
years old in Scotland and played with
the boys and like there's all these
episodes in her in you know in her bio
and over the years that I mean she's
remarkable so how cool very cool
um the AI episode remember when we did
that Adam the AI the AI episode today
Sam Altman of open AI was getting in the
Senate getting grilled right he's
getting grilled on possible
regulation right yeah well that's that's
a case of of the tech Titan realizing
that he has to appear uh friendly to
regulatory Regulators to sort of say we
need regulation we want regular yeah
this is the friendly not really it's not
a hostel what is the succession you know
Season about like you know going and
before Congress and talking about
regulation it's sort of like yeah like
what would cousin Greg say well we we
kind of like regulation do we like it I
would love to see cousin Greg getting
getting uh we like regulation right oh
we don't like it we saw Tom in the
hearings right Tom was in the hearings
Tom would be Tom would be the guy yeah
that's right Tom was Tom was in there
right I forgot about yeah yeah yeah
um and then
and then these these sort of elected
official bureaucrats who are trying to
wrap their heads around AI like you
can't I I you know it's hard to imagine
the complexity of this is so intense
like how do you how does someone who's
not fully immersed in this world
understand the best way to regulate it I
don't know we did a whole episode it was
kind of trying we we thought we were
behind when the episode came out turns
out we were way ahead like since the
episode came out we called out there's
gonna be a AI written uh screenplay
South Park dropped their episode we
called out there's going to be AI
written novels they're all over the
place you know like it's happening we're
using so many AI tools here in our
workflow now it's insane but it's
creating unreal efficiencies yeah so we
can do more of the cool creative stuff I
am AI right now this isn't even Adam of
course this is an AI in a Laker sweater
I'm having a light a light bulb moment
right
um but I bring up AI because there's a
couple interesting AI themed series out
there right now uh that I've enjoyed uh
the first one is rabbit hole with Kiefer
Kiefer Sutherland okay which is kind of
a taught fun Thriller in the style of 24
where he plays uh a guy who is hired by
corporations to do corporate Espionage
you know and and then all of this sort
of intrigue happens as a result of uh
these of an AI related kind of situation
which makes it fun but it's fluffy
network television but it was a fun
watch and then there's this show called
Mrs Davis have you seen this show I have
not this show which is on peacock the
streaming service peacock
was created by one of my favorite
writers in Hollywood Damon Lindelof who
is the genius Master Storyteller also a
dream podcast guest yeah right I'd love
to get him yeah um behind first he's
known best for lost uh right and then
was on the receiving end of so much
criticism on Twitter as a result of the
way that lost ended that he quit Twitter
to spare his mental health but he went
on to create The Leftovers on HBO he is
the genius behind Watchmen on HBO which
is an extraordinary uh limited series
which everyone should watch and he wrote
Prometheus which I think is a highly
underrated and misunderstood
uh exploration of the origin of mankind
that's set in the extended alien
Universe did you see Prometheus no yeah
it's a very cool and he did a Twitter he
was doing a Twitter novel or something
during or he did that yeah I remember
that he came back to Twitter and did it
during uh I remember I remember I
remember something about that oh no no
it was before he was part of
um next draft newsletter you know that
newsletter next draft and he was he was
writing I believe he was writing a
Serial novel oh I don't know yeah I
don't know yeah um he he recently uh
ankled as they say in Hollywood a new
Star Wars project so he's angled I mean
you don't know that no do you live in
Los Angeles
do you even variety or Hollywood
Reporter Adam no but that's sort of like
the parlance of the trade Rags where
they're like like when an executive
leaves one studio and goes to another
they say they angled Sony for DreamWorks
ah you never heard that never heard it
yeah that's Insider talk anyway
um but uh Outsider baby anyway
so Damon has co-created this new series
called Mrs Davis okay
um that he that he uh co-created with
this veteran TV writer called uh Tara
Hernandez and she's really the one who's
running the show he's more in the
background but his fingerprints are all
over this thing because if Damon is
anything he's somebody who knows how to
create really compelling unique uh
stories that just defy your expectations
and and always you know take you places
you never expected to go and I don't
want to give out spoilers for this show
other than to say it's kind of a
heightened semi comedic Sci-Fi series
where a nun uses her faith to
essentially wage war on an all-powerful
super AI that everybody else is in love
with so if you think of it as this kind
of like the most advanced
algorithmic her you know the movie her
yeah in the form of this like Ear Pod
that everybody has in their ear where
they're in constant communication with
right you know super Consciousness is
sort of like if chat GPT became a
religion
and this AI that's called Mrs Davis
sends this nun on a mission to find the
holy grail and then it just goes like
bananas from there and so sexy none on a
mission to find the Holy Grail kind of
and basically AI yeah yeah I'm in it's
it's I mean come on right I'm in yeah
this nun who's trying to destroy the
all-powerful AI and that's not even the
crazy part yeah
um you know everything that Damon has
ever done uh is is just you know super
unique and fresh and unexpected and
unpredictable and wildly entertaining uh
but also and this show certainly does
that manage to manages to you know
grapple with with big questions in this
show in in a really fun way not in your
face but kind of operating in the in the
backdrop is you know this this these
these sort of um
you know big questions around existence
and what is God and you know the
singularity and stuff like that which
makes it pretty fun so anyway I would
check that one out okay uh those are my
big ones okay you know I'm a sucker as
I've said before by anything CIA Mossad
MI5 MI6 so I rushed through slow horses
while I was in London all right I'd go
deep Brit while I was there and I really
enjoyed that
um which is on apple plus I think right
so you're doing you're you're you're
you're you're just knocking out episodes
before bed usually right in the tents
yeah on the plane yeah I have a lot of
playing time yeah so I fired up a lot of
this yeah flying around uh and let's
face it uh Jack Ryan is returning June
30th on Amazon pure dad core
like just you should be able to get him
on Bring It On can't you go through
um
through uh I can't ask rain for that you
can't ask rain no they're still in touch
right remember when remember when
um
Kaczynski during the pandemic did that
good news YouTube show he should have
kept doing that I think he sold the
rides or something like that and then I
don't know what happened they were gonna
just disappeared yeah yeah nothing ever
happened no but that was pretty cool I
mean that was an incredible example of
right place right time right guy and
everybody just wanting something to feel
good well also because he went he made
this conscious decision to do action
stuff and he was smart he was making and
it's probably what he loved to make and
wanted to make and he got buff and all
that but like
the good news was back to Jim almost it
was like if Jim was doing it from it you
know what I mean it was almost like more
gym right like there's just the
wholesomeness yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly yeah which was cool um so those
are my picks for now I mean I had a few
other things here I mean on the podcast
front uh there were a couple interesting
things that I stumbled across I think I
mentioned this podcast series called the
new gurus did I talk about that with you
before this woman Helen Lewis he's not
mentioned it to me yeah who writes for
the Atlanta did a series a podcast
series on the kind of Guru sphere yes
particularly you know in the content
YouTube podcast space
um
she recently released this bonus episode
on the manosphere which I thought was
super interesting okay like the
influence of male podcasters on young
men that I thought was fascinating and
uh is for the better and worse I guess
yeah right right right
um and Rick Rubin launched his podcast
Tetra gramaton Have you listened to any
of those episodes yeah why not but do
you know what that word means
I had to look it up no
is the Hebrew name for God translated in
four letters I thought I thought it was
r-i-c-k Rick I don't know
no like Yahweh without the vowels okay
right okay
um anyway uh it's pretty cool he's doing
something really unique and original in
the long conversation space okay
um he had Alejandro
I know I'm mispronouncing his last name
the director behind uh Birdman and Babel
uh he had Phil Jackson on you're going
to want to tune into that one of Phil
Jackson
um it's cool so I would check that out
as well
and uh we'll check that out that's it
this concludes the media diet
you know what you're a good person to do
the media I've always been like can I
say I've always been an advocate of the
media diet you've always kind of shied
away you're like who cares what I watch
people care but what's funny no given
the kind of themes and context of this
podcast you would think I'm gonna say
here's a documentary and here's this you
know really philosophical deep peace
that's going to change your life and you
know I'm kind of just sharing
entertainment and fresh which feels a
little bit orthogonal to
the you know
recurring themes and focus of the show
so it feels indulgent but it's really
fun too you know but it also shows the
art side it shows your kind of why you
are attracted to the entertainment
business as a lawyer because you love
film and you know it shows that you you
we do have a question a listener
question I think it's the last one that
we're going to answer we're we're being
asked for stories from that period of my
life yeah of which I have many so I bet
if you're interested in that stuff stick
around to the end meanwhile I watch
sports and I'm still watching Apocalypse
Now I started it three weeks ago and
then I'm watching it in like 10. this is
what happens when you have a young with
a toddler it's like you have plenty of
time to go to Lakers and Dodgers games
and watch sports for like hours and
hours a day but Apocalypse Now takes you
a week to get through a week yeah that's
a good that's a good week
you have a small child it's
understandable exactly the kids are
grown yeah you got time you're in the
tent you're like I'm Gonna Knock Out
five spy shows no uh anyway
um what do we got next are we gonna go
we're gonna go right into the AMA we are
but first a wardrobe change
hi my name is
fun fatherhood I am expecting my first
child in about a month and I'm really
excited and really nervous and I really
respect both of your guys's opinions and
would love any tips or advice on
becoming a dad
great question Sam thank you uh for that
uh Adam yes you're not only a new dad I
think you're a parenting you're a
self-help Guru you have some parenting
advice calling me it's been 15 years
since I had an infant calling me a
parenting Guru Step Up own your space
Adam what is the advice you have for Sam
I will say this as an older dad I was 48
when Zuma was born
I have a natural inclination to what I'm
about to say but
um because being an older dad there's
certain advantages there's disadvantages
of course physically and and otherwise
but one advantage is
um you know when you have the baby and
you go through that process and labor
and your wife does it and you're there
the excitement is just everywhere you
know you feel the excitement you feel it
from other people your neighbors your
family your friends having the baby this
new life in your hands it's exciting and
and dizzying
um but that Fades and I think what any
new parent needs to do is accept more
than the excitement more than embracing
excitement because the excitement's
going to happen the really the next
stage is complete acceptance except this
new phase you are in
do not compare it to anything that came
before do not compare it to your other
friends that are in different seasons of
their lives
except exactly where you are and what
your new role is and you'll have a much
easier time staying in the moment as as
a an older dad that came easy to me
since I had basically a full adult life
not being a parent I didn't have this
any sort of fomo whatsoever it was easy
for me to not give a [__] about anything
else and just kind of really click in
but I do notice uh younger parents that
isn't more of an issue and it's of
course it's like human nature so I sent
I don't know how old Sam is but I would
I that that's a piece of advice I give
myself even right so this is not just me
talking to you it's me talking to me
um I'll also exercise grab what you can
you got to stay fit you gotta you gotta
do that from the out outset you don't
want to try to catch up like six months
later
um so catch you know 30 minutes is all
you got go get a 30 minute you know take
them on take as soon as the baby can go
outside go on long walks go on walks
with your family
um and then when you can start to run or
do what you have to do to stay fit
change as many diapers as you can early
on just just be there be there for your
partner be kind to her be kind to
yourself be kind to the baby you'll go
far and say no to the snoo no to the
snoo what is this new this is the snooze
bar it's that no the snoo is the
this bassinet contraption that you kind
of you swaddle the baby and you strap
them down and it like rocks them back to
sleep so you don't have it's it's to get
babies to sleep through the night and
it's supposedly like a sleep training
without the without the uh mean kind of
cold shoulder aspect to it and I we he
you know Zuma was a great sleeper up to
four months and he got too big for the
snoo and supposed to be six months so we
didn't have a chance to like do what
they say to kind of phase it out phase
it out but in really in retrospect it's
kind of a crutch and it it doesn't
really help like once you take the stew
out of the out of you're starting at
zero so we had we thought we were
getting you know we had whole nights
with Zuma four months and then this
first sleep regression happened took him
out of this new and it's like it was
like bananas so that's interesting we
had it we had well first of all that's
great advice hey thank you you are a
self-help Guru you wrote on the outline
acceptance is your golden chalice yes
and then you didn't actually say that
out loud and I'm thinking this is the
title of your parenting book Adam
acceptance is your golden chalice are
you [__] kidding me excitement is at
your fingertips but acceptance a guru
would come up with that phrase when I
speak about when I give advice to people
I try to just make sure my fingertips
are connecting
right a certain manner so I really look
like I'm I've thought this through yeah
projecting confidence presence calm yeah
when I'm 98 and I finally get my TED
talk it's gonna be full fingertips
connecting the whole time right okay
good although I do take issue with this
new thing I I would say
it was a lifesaver for us to have you
know I don't we didn't call it a snoo
but it was like this hammock thing and
we hung it from the ceiling
and it had a little bit of a spring in
the in the in the um cord right and it
was right next to Julie's side of the
bed and so if the baby started crying we
could put the baby in the in the in the
hammock in the sling and the movement of
the baby gently you know makes the thing
bounce a little bit that puts him back
to sleep and that was a lifesaver so I
tell all young parents that they should
invest in that now you had a transition
like kerfuffle right but like if you
figured out how to segue out of that
right
um that was very helpful actually for
those middle of the night situations yes
but that seems gentle compared to what
the snoo does which is like see this is
a different thing yeah this is like a
sling that hangs and it was beautiful
like organic I don't remember the model
of it right I'm sure people can find it
um but yeah acceptance that's huge I
agree with that
um you know not comparing it anything
that came before
is super important I you know agree with
that completely I think it's very easy
for a young father a young parent
to you know project or develop an
attachment or an expectation of what
it's going to be like because we've been
imagining it for so long and we've seen
it portrayed not only in friends and
family but on television and in movies
and we think we're supposed to have a
certain type of response when the baby
comes and you know we think about you
know sort of modeling ourselves after
after you know what we've seen out in
the world and I think everybody is
different you know there's this
narrative it's love at first sight you
see the baby and your life changes in a
moment and it's never the same and
that's true for some people but that's
not true for everybody and I know lots
of
Young Fathers who actually had to play a
little bit of catch up with that where
they couldn't connect immediately
because there's no personality yet
there's no like you know it's hard to
you know yes this is your your child
um but the development of the emotional
bond for a lot of people is something
that just only emerges
um over a more extended period of time
so because I've heard that story so many
times like I always want to let people
know like you shouldn't if you're not
feeling the way that you think you're
supposed to be feeling like everything
is okay with that and kind of let that
go and forget about that projection or
that ideal
um and to be in acceptance It's really
about like showing up and being flexible
and being kind right yeah and you're
just like if you're in a disposition
where you're just waiting for things to
calm down or when is it going to be like
kind of normalized like you're going to
drive yourself crazy so just being cool
with the flow of obstacles coming up
constantly and you not getting your way
and things not kind of going the way
that you would like in order for you to
be rested for your job or whatever it is
like it's just not going to go that way
and you can either get on board with
that or you can resist it but that
resistance is only going to create more
suffering for yourself yes so
you know I think that's a big thing and
you're going to be sleep deprived so
your coping mechanisms are going to be
compromised right but they're not going
to be
in the type of deficit that your partner
is experiencing and so also true you
know you got to be really conscious of
like not like being this you know like I
need the being so is like they're
enduring 100 times more than whatever
you're experiencing so shut your mouth
suck it up and like be cool especially
you know when you come if you I don't
know if you're having a hospital or
whatever we did it in the hospital and
came home and
um you know like they've gone through a
car crash so you know that you know
especially those first days you got to
be on point you got I mean you have to
be on point any time but that first day
oh man you better be on point yeah
because you're gonna be the primary
caregiver yeah really so prepare for
that now yeah what is that going to look
like how can you be best prepared to do
that how can you anticipate needs I
think is a is a is a really big one
um
and uh and uh you know forgetting about
whatever your old routine was because
that's gone you know so judging yourself
against your ability to adhere to the
way you used to kind of navigate your
day is a losing battle
um so just try to create a reasonable
sustainable framework going forward and
just being in the flow I I think also a
huge thing is
um
learning how to anticipate the needs
like I said of your partner like if you
can read your partner's mind you know it
would be helpful to get O's in here to
teach us how to be mentalists for our
partners so you can get ahead of that he
would tell you it doesn't work he
doesn't it doesn't do it it doesn't work
okay
um yeah and just always being mindful of
of what your partner needs and being in
that space of service I think is huge
and yeah you're going to have to find
moments where you need to take care of
yourself but whatever those moments are
uh be sure that your partner is getting
more of those then you know than you are
like uh whatever you can do whatever you
can afford uh to make sure that your
partner is getting self-care like if you
can afford the occasional night nurse or
you can like then you should do that
right if you can't uh then you know
Finding other ways to provide breaks I
think for for her is super important and
then the other thing I would say is as
somebody who whose kids are older now
it's just so fast and I know that's a
tired you know trope
or cliche but it really is true it's
insane how quickly if they're cliches
for a reason like Mathis is traveling
Europe right now with her boyfriend and
is going to college next year and it's
like yesterday she was a baby and I
shared a picture on Instagram for
Mother's Day of
um Julie pregnant with Mathis uh you
know in her belly and it just doesn't
feel like that long ago you guys look
like kids and when they're babies the
phases come and go so quickly as you
know right so learning how to really be
present for all of those phases I think
uh will enhance your Joy through the
experience but it sounds like you're
excited about it and uh so you know
you're already and having another baby
oh you're talking to him yeah Sam exam
it sounds like Santa's excited yeah um I
mean the fact that he's even asking the
question yeah he's miles ahead of of
most impending deaths yes when I start
to feel like am I really living up to my
potential as a parent like
um and I call friends or I share that
they're like well the fact that you're
thinking about it and you're processing
it and you're seeking advice on this uh
already means that you're you know
trying to navigate this with more
conscientiousness than most people so I
don't know Kendall asked uh was talking
what asking aloud about it you know I'm
not sure I'm a great dad and in his case
he's right he wanted shiv to let him off
the hook there so badly okay in his case
in his case he's right he's a shitty dad
anyway
um cool let's go to the next one all
right we're going to Boston
hi my name is Karen I live in Boston and
this is really a big broad question it's
about your dreams not the dreams you
have when you're asleep but
your goal in life what you want to
achieve in your life
the situation that I have or that I'm in
is that I have this vision for who I
want to be in the world and that's
really reflected through the work that I
do I work for myself and I have a very
specific Niche that I help in a specific
way that I do it and I absolutely know
that I'm in my zone of genius and my
zone of Dharma when I do that work
however it's not ramping up at a rate
that allows me to support myself and
this is one of the pieces of it that I
really want to get in place and I keep
telling myself because I'm in my Dharma
it's going to happen but I guess my
question is how long do you try to make
something work when you know in your
heart it's what you're destined to do
like the Mark Twain quote that rich just
had on his podcast like I know it's what
I'm destined to do
however I have yet to see the 3D results
that allows me to
have a sustainable business and support
myself so that's my question I hope it's
clear
and any inspiration you can provide I
would love Namaste all right let's do
I'll go first hot taking then Rachel
weigh in with the with the wisdom I'm
going going in hot
um Karen it sounds to me like you're
already doing it you're already doing
the thing
and as someone who had a goal
um like a life goal to become a writer
and it wasn't always working at first
and you know the definition to me was
being a professional I understand the
impulse
to think about the money and if the
money isn't what you want it to be or to
be sustainable as a career on its own
you feel like you're not doing it you
feel like you're you're actually not
there
um but in reality you are already there
uh because you know what you want to do
and you're doing it already and and
you're doing it at a high level and so
you are there you know the business side
is an altogether different question it's
not the same question as you know
you've already solved the real riddle
people are trying to figure out which is
what what do I want to do who who am I
the business side is just something
specific it's like
um and that is a riddle that there's
there's people out there that can help
you solve I don't know what your
business is but
um just because you're not making a
living at something does not mean that
thing is not worth orienting your life
around it doesn't mean that it's not
worth doing it doesn't so you got to be
careful not to fall in the Trap of
because I'm not making a living at it
I'm not doing it because that's not true
um and if you know a good recommendation
Liz Gilbert talks about this Dynamic and
big magic a lot
um it's just something that she talks
it's kind of on the side but that's a
good reference point for this that book
big magic and just talking about like
it's not necessarily your plan
that it's not supposed to unfold in a
way that you've already envisioned it
doesn't have to it can unfold in its own
way and it sounds like you're doing it
already so that's that's my main point
is just don't lose sight of that Adam
I'm sitting here thinking about how hell
and Lewis is going to have to do another
bonus episode of the new gurus featuring
Adam skolnick's life advice because
you're so good at this
another book oo
no more soon your Dharma
Dime Store Dharma wisdom from Adam's
school that's pretty good
my my take is you know no different than
what you had to say I mean first of all
yes you know congratulations Karen on uh
not only knowing what your dream is but
being extremely clear on that fact and
not only pursuing it but actually living
it
but not recognizing it as the gift that
it is I mean it's pretty rare that
people kind of stumbled upon what it is
that they want to do pursue it and and
really you know live it on a day-to-day
basis so I would acknowledge yourself
for that that's a gift that many would
kill for and immediately puts you in in
a very privileged Place uh so I think
connecting with that might provide a
little bit of gratitude for where you're
at right now instead of
um criticizing yourself or
um wondering why it's not generating
Revenue you know instead shift the lens
a bit one away from lack and guilt
because your Dharma doesn't also happen
to be a revenue generator
and turn it on that gratitude piece
because you're doing something that's
providing you with purpose and happiness
and and meaning the second thing I would
say which is in total agreement with
Adam 100 is that you're doing the thing
and that you shouldn't confuse the thing
that brings you Joy and makes you feel
alive and gives you a sense of purpose
and provides meaning and purpose and
fulfillment with the thing that pays the
bills because I think it's a fallacy and
an illusion that the these things are
can be or or should be even the thing
from which you derive money let alone
make a living but in our culture what we
do how we make a living is how we craft
our identity right so if you're a thing
that you're really passionate about
isn't the thing that is your job or your
vocation then somehow it it holds lesser
sway in how you construct The Narrative
around your identity so I think you know
just kind of understanding how you can
decouple those two things might give you
a little bit of
um
Comforts and and and space
uh and what else do I want to say I mean
if these two worlds happen to line up
like your your passion and the thing
that uh produces finances economics and
and
ethosonomics or whatever you want to
call it then that's great and you're
lucky but it's hard to say if this is or
isn't a possibility in your case because
we actually don't know the details of
the thing that you're doing right um but
the important piece is that it doesn't
have to be that way it rarely is and in
many perhaps most cases maybe it
shouldn't be because once you introduce
economics into that thing that you know
gives you like sustenance it has a
tendency to corrupt the thing to corrupt
to kind of degrade the purity of it and
over time can suck the joy out of it all
together like you we see this even in
like pick any professional athlete who's
shooting around in their sport for too
long like that thing that they love
doing as a kid is now you know this
massive Revenue generator and it's not
fun anymore it's like a whole different
relationship with that thing so there's
gifts in that thing not being the thing
from which you're you know extracting
resources yeah
um but the question was how long do you
keep doing it right if it's not kind of
headed in the direction that you want it
to go in terms of creating Financial
stability I mean the answer is the rest
of your life if this is the if this is
your Dharma right
the question of you abandoning it or or
giving it up shouldn't even be entering
your Consciousness no but what you
should be thinking about is how to
incorporate it into your life in a
sustainable way and maybe if you detach
from that pressure or interest in having
it be a revenue generator and you really
develop this new relationship of doing
it for the thing just to do it to do it
for the joy of it
I don't know man sometimes that's where
the magic happens and doors start
opening and it leads you in a different
direction because your relationship with
that thing is pure and no doubt about it
um I think of two things one is I
remember doing a story on Polynesian
healing and healers and I met this
awesome Kahuna in Tahiti papayate and
he was telling me that he can't earn a
living
practice you know Kahuna is like a
shaman right in Bryson man and so he
can't earn a living by healing so people
turn up at his house with like you know
livestock or with you know uh something
they made at home or some sort of craft
or or item commodity that's never money
and that's old school sub stack yeah I
mean that's way old school but like it's
that's like Beyond old school that's
like Roots you know and and that comes
from a place of the Purity like you're
talking about it right but on the other
hand I mean there are business like
there are life coaches that are
specialized as business coaches right I
mean you heard of that before or is
there are there there must be some
Consultants you can talk about like
there is like I said like figuring out
how to make a better living at something
that's a different riddle and it can be
solved I'm sure it can be solved right
again it's hard to know in in her
particular case because we don't know
what the thing is but I can tell you
that in my case
trying to figure out how to translate
these things that I was interested in
into a vocation was a very you know long
and difficult and drawn out process uh
that required you know a lot of faith
and and toil and hard work and you know
pivots and the like uh it certainly
didn't happen overnight but you got to
stay in it to win it if you really do
want to translate it into I'm sure
there's some way of bringing on people
who are entrepreneurs or business
Wizards or coaches who can look at what
you're doing and try to figure out a
model that might work
so maybe seek that out as you know a way
of
getting help in that specific area or
maybe you're already in the middle doing
it maybe you're already in the middle of
like figuring that out and you don't
even realize it you know what I mean
right so it's like what if what if the
thing that she's doing is generating her
10 million dollars a year but she just
feels like she needs you know 30 million
dollars a year
it's just not quite cutting it Adam it's
her Dharma but you know it's not working
out financially it's her Dharma but you
know she wants floor seats at the Laker
game
um all right or Celtic game she's up
she's in Boston all right okay move on
moving on to a place called Fargo North
Dakota hello rich and Adam this is Simon
from Fargo North Dakota uh many of your
guests on your show talk about shifting
mindset whether it's around positivity
love or other outlooks on life and I'm
wondering if you have any tips for
embracing this team once you've
acknowledged a desire to change how do
you enact these mindset changes in your
life I'm loving the new roll-on format
and thanks for all you do uh well Adam
you know you're on a roll like I said
keep rolling I'm gonna go to the
bathroom you just take this one Simon is
loving the new roll-on format how about
that
um I don't have much to say here other
than
um I've always thought that we are the
sum total of our actions like it or not
so small actions that reinforce any
change in mindset is crucial so any you
know and that could be it doesn't have
to be an act of physical action if what
you're trying to do is go from a
negative First mindset to a positive
first like half cup cap cup half empty
to have cup half full sometimes it's
really just note remember noticing when
you Trend negative and try to come with
an appreciation a thought of gratitude
in that moment I had that exact thing
happen to me when I kind of started to
change my my Outlook in life as a I
think I was 22 and just
that switch flipped in a way
um that was like life-changing for me
but it took conscious thought and I
still do it it takes sometimes you have
to take it takes conscious conscious
mental notes basically at all times to
get yourself to that point where you're
really starting to see the world with a
positive outlook first but you know at
the same time I am
I think naturally optimistic
um but like like doing that would help
and then any sort of action that follows
that thought any you know like you say
thought follows action right or is it
action follows thought I forget what you
say action first
thought follows action so you agree with
this so the way I think about it I agree
with all of that yeah and this is a
subject matter that you're kind of
tiptoeing around that I was trying to
get at in that recent monologue episode
yes the yin and yang of change on the
one hand there is this
um mindfulness presence Eastern peace
which is when you're paying attention
you can notice the recurrences of your
thoughts and you can catch yourself
before you react mindlessly and you can
decide to behave differently and you can
re remember like oh here I am doing that
negative thing I'm not going to do that
anymore okay here's my opportunity to do
the positive thing and that only happens
when you slow things down and you
develop that muscle of mindfulness and
paying attention and being present the
other side of it is the action piece so
um the mindfulness piece is like it can
be like a lightning bolt like you could
change change your mind and your life is
different all at once yeah it can happen
in an instance so there's the lightning
bolts and then there's the bricklaying
part the action part the atomic little
pieces the James Clear kind of
um habit forming uh behavior that leads
to incremental change over time and I
think both of those things are important
mood follows action action first mood
follows the mindset changes and the
emotional changes so all of these things
emanate from action So when you say I
want to change my mindset first of all
great let's recognize and applaud you
for you know having that uh you know
desire but I think everybody kind of
wants to be better has a desire for
their life to be a little bit better
than it is so let's not make too much of
that uh the real
rubber meets the road when we start
talking about how you translate that
desire into something anything Behavior
right it's all about execution and
action So when you say I'm looking for a
mindset change a what does that mean
that's such a vague thing I want to be
more positive still super vague you have
to be very specific you can't just
suddenly start thinking differently
because mindset is like I said both a
reflection and a product of of behavior
and it's less about what you're thinking
and it's more about what are you doing
on the bricklayer side of things like
act first the mind will follow mood
follows action and that is effective
when you have Clarity specificity and
structure around what that looks like
and so you need to you need to translate
that desire to change into first like
what does it look like and what are the
doable repeatable sustainable actions
that you can take every single day like
James Clear talks about in atomic habits
and how do you
protect them and prioritize them so that
they're repeatable and sustainable
within the construct of your busy life
if it becomes disruptive to your life
you're setting yourself up for failure
the people who are successful who make
are the people who are able to make
those tiny invisible Atomic tweaks
repeat them enough until they become
rote and then build upon them so their
lifestyle shifts gradually in you know
kind of proportion to the changes that
are being made and you kind of expand in
this organic gradual way
um
and I think uh it's going to be
different for different types of changes
and goals like mindset goal again what
does that mean specific but if it's
something that can be tied to a date on
the calendar like it's I want to run a
marathon there's a mindset shift that's
going to take place as a result of
setting that goal and doing the
preparation to get across that finish
line and that destination date on the
calendar is your deadline and you work
backwards from there to create the
atomic habits the stepping stones that
are gonna move you in that direction so
that's always good but not all goals are
time Bound in that way and there's
nothing wrong with that either because
ultimately what we're looking for is a
lifestyle shift that is going to stay
with you and isn't going to expire when
you cross that Finish Line right which
causes all the relapses and the kind of
you know reverting back to the norm that
we see with people who are trying to
make changes
um
I also think it's really important to
strike when the iron is hot because
those moments of willingness like I'm
ready to change they they're fleeting
and they pass quickly so when you notice
yourself experiencing that level of
willingness I think it's important to
develop what the reflex or the habit of
actually Translating that as immediately
as possible into doing something like
taking an action a specific action
that's repeatable because uh it's a very
kind of you know as
um Liz Gilbert I'm sure would agree like
these things live in in the cloud you
know what I mean like if you're not
grabbing them quickly they're gone right
so presence the the lightning bolt kind
of mindfulness aspect of being aware
when that willingness arises and then
the bricklayer piece of like I I'm
willing right now what can I do what
choice can I make in this moment that's
going to kind of just tweak my
trajectory a little bit and then how do
I build upon that how do I
um protect and prioritize the
repeatability of whatever it is I just
did how to then create momentum and then
re respect that momentum because once
you've string you string together even a
couple days of something that's real you
know there's a power in that there's a
reason why streaks are such a you know
such a thing we have hella you know
about to celebrate six whatever years
six thousand whatever you know whatever
the guys run every day for a long time
right and he's not going to wake up
tomorrow not run no there's so much
momentum behind this streak and the
repeatability of this action that he
decided to take a long time ago and and
that's something that I think you have
to really uh respect I love that that's
a great job no accountability I think is
is Big accountability to yourself like
if this is really important and then
accountability to other people as long
as you're choosing wisely like who you
select to be accountable for make sure
it's somebody who really wants the best
for you and isn't gonna you know kind of
work across purposes with you building
this new Behavior set that's a good
point like the accountability aspect and
the momentum aspect you know I I uh I
didn't think about the accountability
part I also think patience is huge and
I've been beating this drum forever but
everybody wants these changes to happen
so fast and when they don't see
immediate results or anything noticeable
uh it's just easy to revert back but
these things are hard they take a long
time they're non-linear it's you know
one step forward two steps backward all
that kind of stuff and so if you're
thinking about it in what Gordo Byrne
called on the podcast like thousand day
increments or decades or even years as
opposed to well in six months I want to
be this allow yourself you know that
room and be
gracious with yourself when you slip
because that's part of the process and
not hold yourself to some unrealistic
set of expectations or rules around
perfectionism you're going to be in a
better stead and I think it takes 90
days to really even begin the process of
letting go of an old habit and and
building the foundation for a new one is
that a 12-step principle yeah I mean you
know P the 28-day rehab thing I mean
honestly 28 days like
I think 90 days is much more grounded in
in reality in my experience
and even if it is a goal with a date on
the calendar I think it's important to
you know it's cool to like have that as
a North star to to motivate you and
something to work towards but it's also
important to not be to destination
oriented this is the other yin and yang
right like you have to be loose with it
the goal is long-term change which means
you know moving towards this better self
where your actions uh
cohere to a greater extent
with your values they're a greater
reflection of of your values I mean
that's the real role here right right
change and that's meaningless if it's
flimsy or
um doesn't stick and you think overnight
switch flipping change tends to not
stick as much as incremental change I
just think it's it's you know it's very
contingent
specific conditions it's contextual it
depends on the person and the situation
you know people make a decision I'm
going to go vegan they never eat meat
again I'm going to go sober today they
never drink again and then some people
relapse and relapse and relapse and
relapse and they put together a year or
two and maybe for the next 10 years they
only drank a couple times and it's not
perfect everybody's different it's your
relationship to that and it's the you
know how are you spending most of your
time compared to what it used to look
like and
um
I think we're all really hard on
ourselves when it comes to this kind of
stuff and when we experience failure or
it becomes difficult like we just we
give up too soon that's [__] great
man that was a hell of a rant I loved it
um all right yeah so thank you Simon for
the question fantastic yeah let's go to
Josh this next one uh I'm gonna play it
for you I just want to make sure you
know listeners know he's really choosing
his words carefully
um it sounds halting at times but I
think it's because it's an emotional
question and he's choosing his words
extremely carefully which I uh had a lot
of you know respect for is it's obvious
what was happening and and and his words
are you know well chosen so just so you
know going in
hi I'm Josh Casey Portland Oregon I'm
curious what has helped you specifically
connects with your teenage children what
started open communication what were the
first steps around awareness of maybe
even transparency around your sobriety
and the teenage experience that's
growing within the same household as
yourself like what is an approach that
you've taken and how has it developed or
changed over time I am working with a
teenage
recovery community and developing
mindful practices or Simply Self
reflection across the teenage
demographic and starting those
conversations on how to have a more
mindful conversation around drug use and
what our bodies are circling our
thoughts around or how to
better take care of ourselves is a topic
that I'm struggling in this moment to
have and to support thank you for your
time and energy and conversation around
how we change over time I appreciate it
a lot goodbye
yeah my heart's breaking here in that
um it's pretty heavy
[Music]
yeah I can only infer but I have a sense
that he's dealing with a teenager of his
own who's going through something that
he's struggling to understand and figure
out how to navigate
uh for himself and for his child I don't
know that to be the case but it feels
like that's what's going on here and it
just you know there's
few things harder than knowing how to
how to deal with that
um
and I want to be compassionate
because
it is so hard and there is no right or
wrong or clear
path or way to answer this question
particularly when
the communication Channel
is only trying to be developed now when
you're in an acute crisis situation as
opposed to a history of building that
such that it can be leveraged when that
crisis period arises so it's hard to
construct that In the Heat of a very
challenging situation
um
so I think
you know I would say as a backdrop to
this
I'm a big believer no surprise in in
open communication and transparency with
your kids
um
Josh wanted to know kind of how I've
handled that or how I think about that
and I'm somebody who made a decision to
be very open with my kids about my
addiction and my recovery their whole
lives so they've never known anything
different they've all been to a meetings
with me it's a topic of conversation at
dinner so there's nothing hidden around
that and Julie's shared her history over
those years and I think
that has allowed us to build trust and
create and maintain a Channel of
communication where the kids feel safe
coming to the table and sharing their
experiences because there's no fear of
judgment or
um
or punishment as a result of that
because the most important thing is the
communication piece and and the truth
and the minute that you bring that
punishment sensibility into that Dynamic
the communication shuts down and the
person starts to just they're not it
doesn't change their behavior it's just
puts them in a place where they're going
to start hiding it and lying about it so
I've always been very mindful about that
um and I think you know listen when
teens
when kids become teens they all you know
they become different people like you're
like who is this person you know and
part of that is hormonal and part of
that is a very healthy uh desire to
to uh differentiate that is important in
guiding them towards adulthood uh and
it's to be kind of respected right you
want them to do that so as they become
different rather than resisting it or
being confused by it or being upset
about it like finding ways to dance
around it and embrace it and part of
that is withdrawing from the openness
that you enjoyed when the kids were
younger so it becomes harder to keep
that channel open
um
and I'm I'm sharing this
as no master of this I'm telling you
like we had a lot of Rocky teenage years
and so I've taken my lumps in this world
as well
but I can tell you uh
that
you can't force the kid to open up you
can't force the dialogue you can't
schedule it questions like how is school
or what happened today generally go
nowhere but there are moments if you're
patient
and those moments arise in unpredictable
brief flashes
where if you're spending enough time
with your kid uh just driving or doing
whatever you're doing suddenly they'll
come to you and say something and you
just have to like live for those moments
and appreciate them when they come
because you can't will them into being
and one way into that is to
try to find a way to be interested in
what they're interested in right you
can't
force them to be interested in what
you're like you may think like Oh
They'll love this or this is what I like
so they should like it or I'm going to
take this teen to go do this thing that
I enjoy and teach them that instead what
do they already into are they playing
video games are they listening to music
are they playing a certain sport
whatever it is developing an interest in
that is a way in to connection with the
kids so an example would be let your kid
play the music they want to play in the
car and when a song comes up that you've
never heard before like ask them about
it talk to them about it or you know
what TV show are they walking watching
or what YouTuber do they like and why
and just be curious about their life
without your [__] and your baggage
um tends to work and it's not an
immediate thing but it's a practice I
think that I think is beneficial and it
doesn't matter what you say it's what
you do so you gotta lead by example if
you're interested in you your children
being more mindful then you have to be
an example of mindfulness in front of
them but I think in this acute example
the important thing first of all is
figuring out a way to take care of
yourself I mean clearly
um Josh is suffering right and he is not
in a position to help his teen unless he
takes care of himself and my biggest
suggestion would be that he seek out
um Al-Anon meetings where he has a
community of people who are weathering
similar situations and have a lot of
experience and tools that could be
helpful and or maybe he's sober himself
in his yeah I don't know there's a lot
of question marks here but if that's an
unexplored situation or terrain I would
I would suggest
even if just for the community of people
you know that you can talk to about what
you're going through and maybe extract a
little bit of wisdom that would be
applicable in your life
and then you know assuming Josh has a
teen is going through a drug situation
at the moment understanding that as
painful as it is
there's very little that you can do
to
get the person to stop because that
person has to want to it has to be
willing to if they truly are an addict
or an alcoholic like if this if the
grips of addiction are are really in
there and it's not just teenage
rebellion or a phase or something like
that it becomes very unwieldy and and
difficult to untie that knot so it's a
dance they need to know that you're not
happy with what's going on you need to
make sure that you're not codependent in
the behavior or afraid to confront them
on that behavior and it's certainly
appropriate to create rules around
the teen's Behavior such that if they're
broken there are
there are repercussions to that of
course but the trick is to not be so
emotionally uh activated by the whole
thing and to hold it a little bit more
Loosely because it's so confusing and
confounding to watch somebody engage in
self-destructive Behavior or kind of
Blaze their way towards some
self-destructive end and you know the
way out of that and you can't understand
why they can't see it or they won't do
the right thing Etc it can be you know
baffling and incredibly painful and also
there's this amazing sense of
powerlessness that you have because you
you just can't you can't make it stop no
matter what you do
um
do you intervene do you get a bunch of
people and like kidnap the person in the
middle of the night and put them in the
back of a van and take them off to you
can do that
um
and that person might stay sober for a
little while chances are not for very
long though because it wasn't their idea
so how do you gracefully kind of nudge
them towards
a realization that maybe there's a
better way to live
and I'm certainly no Jedi Master when it
comes to that but I can tell you keeping
Communication open making sure that they
know that you love them and that you're
available for them but not available to
participate in their [__] but
available if and when they're ready to
get help and then finding a way to
create trust in a space where they can
share what's going on with them without
being
uh
on the receiving end of a lot of
judgment I think is is super important
like we have two younger ones one comes
home TMI tells us everything that
happened at the party and it's just like
enough to induce you know a permanent
panic attack what teenagers are doing
Malibu parties yeah
and the other one keeps it all inside
right and it's a mystery box how do I
unlock this person and figure out what
they're thinking and how do I get them
to open up once too open the other one's
not so it's like I've swung between
these extremes and you know I'm trying
to figure it out myself every single day
um but I think they both know
that if they come to me to talk to me
about this kind of stuff that I'm
available and that I'm not going to
judge them and it's okay you know that
the most important thing is that they're
safe and that I love them and that I
care about them and I'm going to take
care of them but that didn't happen in
the heat that that that
sense of trust didn't didn't arise in
the heat of an acute situation it was
kind of created over a long period of
time so I would seek out counsel it
sounds like Josh is already doing that
Al-Anon would be huge
um and again there's no right or wrong I
mean there's nothing more painful than
to watch a loved one suffer and when the
loved one is your child it's just it's
the worst right it is the absolute worst
and
you know I have a lot of compassion for
my parents who were in a lot of pain
when I was going through what I was
going through and I couldn't see that
and I didn't care and you know it's just
when you're in the disease that's all
that matters
so it's not personal
and they're not bad people they're
suffering from
a disease that is distinct from the
person that you love and trying to
remember that I think is important also
and being curious about it just like
being curious about their interests like
hey how'd that go last night how do you
feel like feel good you want to keep
doing that
maybe you need to keep doing it we'll
see how it goes you know how can you be
a little more dispassionate and
unattached to that result and when you
let go of that like
that
um attack like this person needs to get
better and why can't they see it if you
just take all of that away there's a
vacuum and I think the teen will feel
that vacuum all of a sudden like hey I'm
not getting vibed anymore how come
oh it's on me
I mean I don't need to get sober for him
he's off my back now that's all I wanted
I thought I just wanted my parents off
my back now they're off my back
suddenly you have to look at yourself in
the mirror and that can work to prompt a
little bit of self-accountability
not always who knows
um it's just one way of thinking about
it and looking at it and then one day
hopefully there will be a little opening
you know maybe
he or she will come to you and say hey
this isn't working out for me and you
need to be prepared for what to say and
what to do in that moment
compassion non-judgment boundaries
are huge
um taking care of yourself seeking out
counsel and advice not keeping it
uh to yourself the fact that you called
and left this message I think it's huge
but if you can develop the practice of
having conversations with trusted people
who are part of this community who can
help you in your area I think that would
be unbelievable and you're in Portland I
went to treatment in Portland so there's
a Hazelden down in Newburgh and there's
an open a meeting there and they
probably have Al-Anon meetings there
that's where I got sober
um
and I know the recovery community in
Portland is strong and it's very strong
with young people the teen sober
community in in Portland is is kind of a
very cool remarkable thing so
those are my thoughts I hope there's
something helpful in in what I had to
share beautiful heavy stuff Josh good
luck man
here's a fun one a more fun one kind of
to close it out uh and thanks everyone
for your questions
please keep calling the line is open
that's right the voicemail number is 424
now what is it
424-235-4626 there you go and uh keep
them coming because we're gonna keep
doing this
in the meantime here's Mario hey Rich
and Adam this is Mario in Sunny San
Diego California
um thanks for all the years of great
podcasts I've learned so much and it's
helped my life measurably
um but my questions are more of a fun
one rich you never talk about your time
as an entertainment lawyer so my
question was you got any good stories
about uh you're entertainment lawyer
days maybe some crazy client demands or
client behavior of course you don't have
to give any names unless you know you
don't want to thanks that's such a cool
question I don't think anyone's ever
asked me that I don't know if it's
interesting to anybody other than Mario
yeah yeah I got lots of stories let's
hear them it's a little dicey there's a
couple stories probably shouldn't share
those uh a few names that probably are
better left unrevealed the redacted did
you live here it is a town that talks a
lot not that I'm in that world at all
anymore
um so yeah a lot uh disappointingly uh
you know very far from a list
that's even better that's even better
they're better I don't have great Tom
Cruise Brad Pitt stories uh although I
did I did share that I stood next to
Brad Pitt inside the Mercedes garage at
the Formula One race and no words were
exchanged is that an encounter I wasn't
a lawyer anyway you're an extra
um yeah it's you know listen uh
Hollywood's a weird place and and kind
of dancing around the edges of of that
business you're there's just going to be
weird stories that happen and just off
the cuff like I thought about this room
like what are I'm sure there's a million
more but the ones that I had a bunch I
kind of made a list of a few that had
happened
um
I moved to LA to work at this
entertainment firm uh and in short
shrift found myself
working under Robert Shapiro of OJ Fame
so I was his associate on one or two
cases just after two cases I worked on
two k yeah two cases with him so this
was after right I mean I was studying
for the bar when the Bronco Chase
happened and that's the cemented into my
brain forever and if you're like if
you're a younger person listen to the
listening to this it's really hard to
really appreciate or imagine just how
all-consuming the OJ trial was what was
before the trial it was like we just
thought his ex-wife had been killed and
it was really we felt bad for OJ and
next thing you know we turned around and
OJ's On The Run for the tier one border
it was it was like craziest most
riveting thing ever and then of course
everything that you know followed and
ensued after that it just captured
everybody
to such a level that I don't know has
anything since I mean it was a
monoculture back then right that has
kind of vanished right
um there was no Twitter there was you
know a lot of this a lot of this you
know social media wasn't so it was a
different time but anyway it was let me
just say if if if if you didn't
experience it it was a big [__] deal
and like the lawyers representing OJ
were just I mean again seared into your
brain Johnny Cochran yeah well they were
also Kardashians they're just great
characters yeah like yeah the the you
know the Potter familias of the whole
Kardashian thing oh my God tracks back
to OJ yes you know yes and of course
Robert Shapiro
um
so it's very surreal when I suddenly
started working for this guy that I've
been watching on television
and I worked on a matter of you know
some civil suit stuff with him yeah but
I do remember one night
working late in the office
and he was there and me and maybe two
other associates I can't remember we
were eating Chinese food in uh in a
conference room with with Bob call him
Bob yeah uh and we had the TV on and
this was around the Civil verdict in the
civil suit okay and I just remember
watching the news with him of helicopter
point of view over his Brentwood estate
as like people were going in and out of
the house and like taking out his like
prized belongings of that have this
vague memory of that sitting with him
like talking to him about the OJ trial
watching OJ stuff like on the news and
this was like right after I'd moved to
Los Angeles and suddenly I was like at
this firm that was
in you know kind of at the vortex of a
lot of you know Griffin dunn-esque
Vanity Fair type you know Hollywood
Intrigue and disputes and it was kind of
fascinating and bizarre yeah that was my
introduction
um what was his take on it was it was he
like he was just curious well first of
all of all his Partners in this Law Firm
he seemed the happiest
[__] he kind of did his own thing he
sort of had an office there he was sort
of part of the firm but it kind of did
whatever you wanted outside of it
um
yeah I don't know I was too sheepish and
young and and to like really I don't
remember uh talking to him about it
directly I just remember thinking how
strange it was that I was working with
him and anyway I ended up leaving that
firm
um when I kind of was like I can't do
this anymore uh and
a client that I had been working for who
was Bob's client called me and said I
know you left the firm but I could
really use your help on this case that's
still ongoing why don't you just come
and work for me you don't have to go to
a law firm you come to my house and I
had no money and I thought this is cool
so I thought sure I'll do that well
he lived in the Marion Davies estate
behind the Beverly Hills Hotel it is the
house that was built by William Randolph
Hearst for his for his uh
mistress uh and it's a house most of you
are probably familiar with because it
appeared in The Godfather oh and it's
the house the producer's house yes who
wakes up with the horse ad yes and uh I
worked every day at that house
in the pool house right next to that
pool crazy working on a very strange
case uh the details it was a horrible
case though let's just leave it at that
uh yeah I remember Brian Wilson
wandering the halls of the law firm that
I was working for looking like he was
lost and didn't know what was going on I
think he was having his deposition taken
in some battle Brian Wilson of The Beach
Boys yes yeah
um I snuck into Steven Spielberg's
office one night at DreamWorks I
remember that me and a buddy who shall
remember well he had some kind of
business there and he had a friend he's
like oh let's go and well you know we
went into DreamWorks like after hours
and everyone was gone and he's like hey
let's go into Steven's office and we
were like in his office and sitting
behind his desk
Steven Steven I've never met the guy
Steven should lock his office
um I had to go to Richard dreyfus's
house and meet with him at his house in
Rancho Cucamonga once he lives in Rancho
Cucamonga he lives in like uh Ranch
property in San Diego area that was a
very strange meeting that amounted to
nothing I follow his son Ben on uh
Twitter he's funny I represented Michael
Bolton for a hot minute
[Music]
they were kind of new it wasn't the
thing that you used all the time and he
had my cell phone number and I remember
he called me one night when I was laying
in bed with Julie and I was like babe
it's Michael Bolton I gotta take this
call Babe uh would you like to hear
Michael Michael hit it
um
I did I did production legal or not
production legal I did some legal work
financing docs on a movie called The
Cooler which people might remember as
the film starring William Macy and uh
and Alec Baldwin I don't even see that
movie no well Alec Baldwin got an
Academy Award nomination really
occurring in that movie that was the
movie that kind of resuscitated his
career out of the action hero phase and
into kind of better work
um and that was a fun one yeah you
should check it out cooler you never saw
it never saw it uh shout out to my boy
Brett Morrison my friend Brett uh who
was my client on that okay that's one of
the financers of of that film
um
that movie had a wrap party that would
never fly in 2023. okay I'll leave that
there
here's a good one
I helped Rick Schroeder Ricky Schroeder
make a little movie Black Cloud it's
Rick now yeah did some legal work on
that movie was on set
with Rick it's a movie about a Native
American Boxer okay uh and I play a
cameo really
so find that movie seek it out watch it
send me a screen grab can we get a cameo
if you can identify me how can we get it
there's photographic evidence out there
I want to see a screen grab
um on that note I also worked on a movie
called see this movie it was another
little Independent Movie that that uh
shot of Montreal and I did production
legal on that
um that start a young Seth Meyers I
think he had just finished like his
first year at SNL and uh and John show
and that was really fun
um and I also played a bit part in that
movie if you can find it really yeah and
that's how you know Chris White this
brings it back to you because it was
produced by Chris weitz who's your boy
yes
um for those that don't know I mean I
wouldn't say this is I mean I love the
guy but I haven't seen him in a while
he's uh he's an amazing amazing person
he's an amazing talent a great guy and a
better guy him his brother made American
Pie wrote and directed American Pie and
then about a boy and he wrote Star Wars
Rogue one which is great as well and
here's a here's a maybe less known fact
about Chris whites huge burner Burning
Man guy yes that's where he met him so
much so he like he's part of he's part
of like what is the his little his
little tribe or his little Community I
don't know the name but he's something
Galactica you that he was on the board
of like he's heavily involved he was on
the board of Burning Man I think for a
period of time maybe yeah I wouldn't be
surprised that yeah and the reason I
bring that up is we were shooting this
movie I think it was September uh when
is Burning Man August or September well
anyway we were a couple weeks into
production he's like I gotta go I'm go I
gotta go to Burning Man and he just left
the movie in the middle of production to
go to the desert and he was like I think
it's cool that your producer can go to
Burning Man production it means I trust
everybody
I mean he he's uh he's a veteran now you
know like he started out as wonderkins
and they're veterans you know like doing
it all it's amazing amazing career for
both he and his brother Paul right
um he's a brilliant brilliant Talent
yeah um
I did
so on that movie I was part of my job
was negotiating all the talent deals and
and you know creating all the contracts
for them and I don't remember the
details of it but I remember colossally
screwing up Seth Meyer's deal where I
had like stated the wrong rate like his
fee and all that kind of stuff and had
to eat crow and call his agents and I
was like I didn't really know what I was
doing and it was so humiliating
so he thought he was getting paid I
don't know well the information probably
never trickled down to him but I had to
like like call up these agents who were
like this guy's an idiot so he's doing
it all and they were correct about that
but I'll end with maybe my favorite
Hollywood encounter story which is the
time that Sylvester Stallone
complimented me on my calves
they are wonderful calves they are
wondrous they are wondrous uh yeah you
know carved from Granite I was at a sort
of family-oriented event the details of
which are not important but he uh I was
introduced to him and I was wearing
shorts and he wanted to talk about how I
made my calf muscles the way that they
were to which I said ask my mother I
have nothing to do with it
they're just like they just they are
what they are that's what you say but
you're you're they've always been that
way your athletic resume uh they've
always been tell us another story but
anyway
my calves being the Envy of Sylvester
Stallone is the appropriate ending to
this already too long podcast that's
what we do in the old school roll on
Space we go we go long we go
sometimes deep long and occasionally
deep
uh always long occasionally deep yeah
there's another there's another book
title for you always long-winded
occasionally deep there you go uh maybe
we'll do this again you guys let us know
looking forward to your feedback I like
moving back and forth I like it yeah
we're done right I think we go I gotta
go